hey you want to know a fun fact Kevin
what's a fun fact did you know that
lobsters pee from their face cool
Jackie what are we doing today oh you
don't know no we're unboxing a wack
welcome welcome welcome wacom cintiq
frog that's right the good people at
welcome sent us a couple of Cintiq pros
to use on the show so we figured why not
open it in front of all of the internet
scissors right exciting just like giving
a box of c-section be careful No
so this is the box this is a drawing of
the thing that we draw on do you think
they drew that on a Wacom Cintiq here's
the irony I think they probably didn't
done-done okay now help me okay we're
pulling this off I did it
congratulations this is the heaviest
piece of styrofoam ever
I think there's stuff inside yeah this
is the weight don't drop it I'm not
gonna try to drop it it's over not gonna
drop it Jackie
I want to unbox that I want to know the
surprise in wha
would you look at that we got some wires
we got the pen very important and Zardo
seems like we got a futuristic disc
maybe if I press it Kevin will die come
on it's like a Life Alert but the
opposite of death alert here are some
instructions if you don't know how to
plug in screens there's the brick here's
the brick filled with lots of power
there's more cables Jackie
we are lousy with cables okay warning
this bag is not a toy keep this bag away
from babies and children Kevin get out
just kidding Evans an old man Wow very
soon
I think these are like a little simple
stand if you want to do that that's
pretty cool so you don't need a stand
but the nice people are welcome sent us
a stand so we're going to unbox that
stand as well ready Jackie I'm red I
don't see another box I'm not helping at
all
you're not helping Jackie not at all Wow
can I stab it no no stop it opening up
the bigger box
Jackie how do you think our unboxing
video is going I think our unboxing babe
I think our unboxing video is going
pretty good more instructions they're
very huge the REO state lines no no no
this just comes out Oh like a like an
egg just things heavy
okay well Liv drill came with two
packets oh thank you yummy don't eat
these they literally say on them do not
eat I just feel like that's a challenge
for me look it says decadent silica gel
does not say that it says desiccant
decadent Tessa can't it's a very
different jacket is silica don't eat the
silica gel whatever you do don't eat the
soil
oh it says donut eat mmm we're gonna
assemble the stand which will take us a
couple hours but for you we'll only be a
couple short seconds
we did it it took us no time at all
took us a very long time actually but we
put it together yeah we did it was a
good time so this is a Cintiq 24 HD
touch it is a touchscreen that's crazy
so you can zoom in and zoom out with a
pinch yeah just like how you use on your
phones
that's for you Millennials alright
Jackie I say you and I do a collab on
our new Cintiq here how about you do the
sketch I do the inks oh wow right that's
gonna be wild and wacky right wild and
wacky with Kevin and Jackie we're not
calling it wild kevin and jay alright so
what do you want to draw what are
something that we both like alright one
two three we both love avocados okay are
we gonna draw a regular avocado or raw
avocado person let's do another kind of
person okay okay so avocados are shaped
like they look like little pairs if
pears were delicious sure oh I love
those pencils do you guys have this you
guys have this pencil tool because I do
it's pretty great it feels like I'm
drawing on a real sketchbook just gonna
have a big ol smile oh it's a she yeah
I've given this avocado female perhaps
great she's pregnant
Oh with a little avocado pit a little
baby oh oh you see what happens when you
work together
oh she's holding her little avocado pit
does she have any hair that's adorable
she just loves
turning this a little boat that's very
cute
all right now now Kevin will line my
drawing you see this and I get to adjust
the air ghost and adjust the air ghost
and do my angle I'm gonna make a new
layer I'm gonna drop yours to about 20
percent
that's how sketching works and I'm gonna
take my anchor oh so the cool thing
about Cintiq s-- is that they are
pressure-sensitive so you can start with
a light line and then make it thick just
like just like here's what I typically
do with lines like this i overshoot it a
little bit that's how you get those nice
confident confident lines everyone look
at that see and then we just erase the
part here all right check this out all
right in order to make this line here
I'm gonna rotate this guy are you guys
looking at this it is basically
upside-down yeah I don't and lock them
you are you are crazy
we're getting closer getting close oh
there's a lot of different than what is
it there's like thousands of levels of
pressures and these a lot of levels of
pressure there's a lot of levels of
pressure sensitivity folks do you want
to do color let's do Co I'll do some
color do some color I'll do some add the
adding some color the outside is dark
it's like dark green yeah there we go
yeah I think that's pretty good I like
that I'm gonna make her hat the same
color as our pit okay I am gonna add a
little little shade just gonna go drop
down into the red a little bit bolshy
I like it let me do a little background
on it I want to do like a water color
brush water color big round so the cool
thing about this is that it responds to
the tilts of the brush and the pressure
just like real life just like oh oh look
at that you guys see that
now that's adorable isn't it yeah all
right what do you think I think we did a
good job the two hours of putting the
stand together totally worth it to draw
this avocado
Jackie do we have a name for our avocado
friend
name is a Nakano anakata so we want to
thank our friends at Wacom for sending
us these great monitors you will see
them in future episodes of draw-off so
be sure to stay tuned so on behalf of me
and Jackie and anakata
we want to thank you for watching our
first and probably only unboxing video
we will never ever do this again